herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid wir
sprechen heute zum einen über den
NATO-Gipfel in Venus und dann aber auch
über den ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski in Vilnius venius lasst uns
dafür mal gemeinsam auf folgende Bilder
schauen zu Beginn des Nato-Gipfels in
venius gab es dieses Foto hier mit dem
Start und Regierungschefs inklusive
Schweden als künftig 32 Mitgliedstaat
und auch wenn die litauischen Gastgeber
für die Ukraine als Nummer 33 werden war
Präsident selenski noch nicht dabei der
seht ihr hier kam später zum Gipfel
schickte aber schon vorab Kritik per
Twitter Zitat es ist beispiellos und
absurd das ist weder einen Zeitraum für
eine Einladung noch eine Zusage für
einen NATO für eine NATO Mitgliedschaft
der Ukraine gibt
ja und das ist auch das heutige Thema
dieser Sendung wir wollen diskutieren
tut die NATO aktuell zu wenig für die
Ukraine und wie sehen die
verteidigungspläne aus die die NATO
gegen einen möglichen Angriff Russlands
ausgearbeitet hat das diskutiere ich wie
immer nicht alleine sondern mit Gästen
zum einen mit meinem zdf-kollegen und
nato-korrespondent Florian neuhahn der
für uns live in Vilnius ist und mit
Militärexperte Gustav gresse und wie
immer diskutieren wir auch mit euch da
draußen wenn ihr Fragen an unsere Gäste
habt oder einfach mal eure Meinung zum
Thema mit uns teilen wird dann tut das
sehr sehr gern entweder direkt hier im
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an die
eingeblendete Mail-Adresse mir
zugeschaltet ist jetzt aber erstmal
Militär Experte Gustav gresse hallo Herr
schön dass Sie bei uns sind
ja über diesen silenski Tweet den wir
hier gerade eingeblendet haben da wurde
ja schon viel diskutiert und das Wording
wird auch zunehmend schärfer wie
bewerten sie denn seine Äußerung
aus meiner Sicht ist es verständlich
also die Ukraine hat sich erhofft dass
man eine Einladung bekommt auch wenn die
Einladung zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt wo
der Krieg läuft noch nicht vollstreckt
werden kann aber zumindest einen
Entscheidung dass eben die Ukraine der
NATO Beitritt in diesem kommuniki ist
keine Einladung formuliert da wird
ähnlich wie ein Bukarest 2008 das Thema
vertagt es wurde zwar festgeschrieben
dass die Ukraine keine membership action
plan mehr braucht also keine genaue
Anleitung zu Reformation
ihrer Streitkräfte und ihres
verteidigungsapparates allerdings kam
der membership Action kleinen quasi
durch die Hintertür wieder zurück da man
sozusagen den NATO-Beitritt dann dann
weitere Formen und an einem Prozess
bindet die man genau überwachen wird in
dem Sinn hat die Ukraine trotz des
Krieges der 18 Monate dauert leider
nicht erreicht und das ist natürlich
auch so ukrainischer sich t enorm bitter
ja das klingt erstmal nicht nach einem
raschen Beitritt herrgasse wir sprechen
uns gleich noch mal zu potenziellen
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
jetzt schalte ich aber erstmal zu
unserem NATO korresponden Florian neuhar
nach Vilnius hallo Florian
ja hallo was willius ja der ukrainische
Präsident hat ja schon wieder getweetet
ich mache das hier einmal auf am PC und
zwar schrieb er das müsst ihr euch jetzt
zeitlich also nach diesem ersten Tweet
vorstellen heute habe ich mich mit dem
Glauben an Entscheidungen mit dem
Glauben an Partner mit dem Glauben an
eine starke NATO auf die Reise hierher
begeben in eine NATO die nicht zögert
keine Zeit verschwendet und nicht auf
einen Angreifer zurückblickt und ich
möchte das aus diesem Glauben Vertrauen
wird Vertrauen in die Entscheidungen die
wir verdienen die wir alle und jeder
Krieger verdienen was erwartet jeder
Bürger jede Mutter jedes Kind und ist
das zu viel erwartet die NATO wird der
Ukraine Sicherheit geben die Ukraine
wird das Bündnis Stärken Slava Ukraine
Slava lituawi das habe ich in vilius von
Litauen und Ukrainern gesagt die sich zu
einem Konzert im Rahmen der Kampagne die
Flagge der Ukraine in der nato-hessen
versammelten
ja also auch in diesem Tweet eigentlich
eine sehr starke sehr optimistische
Ansage der
präsidentinenz gesagt die NATO wird der
Ukraine Sicherheit geben und die Ukraine
wird das Bündnis Stärken Florian du bist
ja schon den ganzen Tag jetzt in Vilnius
was ist denn heute ganz konkret in diese
Richtung beschlossen worden
ich würde das genauso sehen wie Herr
gressel ist eben auch gesagt hat die
Hoffnungen der Ukraine auf eine
Einladung wir sind hier eindeutig
enttäuscht worden allerdings kann man
vielleicht auch fragen ob diese
Hoffnungen realistisch waren denn
realistischerweise konnte die NATO kaum
eine direkte Einladung aussprechen es
ging ja hier um eine Frage der Einladung
für einen Beitritt irgendwann also für
die Zeit nach einem Krieg nach einem
Krieg Ende in irgendwann ein
Waffenstillstand geschlossen worden ist
ja und um diesen Zeitpunkt wurde hier
erbittert gestritten es gab eine große
Gruppe an NATO Mitgliedstaaten die sich
eine direkte Einladung einen quasi einen
Automatismus gewünscht hätten in diesem
abschlusskommuniki aber die NATO
entscheidet nicht per Mehrheit sondern
einstimmig und da fehlten eben dann die
Stimmen von gewichtigen NATO-Staaten
allen voran von Deutschland und den USA
zwei Staaten die da einmal auf derselben
Wellenlänge waren und die beide gesagt
haben jetzt sei nicht der Zeitpunkt
gekommen über eine Einladung zu
diskutieren irgendwann jetzt kommen es
darauf an gezielt Waffenlieferungen zu
machen also militärische Hilfe leisten
und passenderweise kamen hier auch
diverse Staats- und Regierungschefs an
mit konkreten Waffenlieferungen etwa der
französische Präsident der hier
Waffenlieferungen versprach ankündigt
aber eben auch der deutsche
Bundeskanzler der einige im Gepäck hatte
ein neues Paket von immerhin wieder mal
700 Millionen Euro darunter auch einige
Panzer die aus der Industrie instand
gesetzt worden sind oder auch ein neues
patriot-gerät zur Flugabwehr also
insofern ist es ein gemischtes Bild aber
die großen Hoffnungen der Ukraine auf
eine Zusage für einen Beitritt eine
Einladung die wurden definitiv
enttäuscht
jetzt hat vor gar nicht allzu langer
Zeit vor ein paar Minuten oder von einer
Stunde der deutsche
Verteidigungsministerium gesagt man
solle erstmal dieses Abschluss Community
von nur von dem du auch gerade abwarten
da würde sicher etwas drin stehen worauf
sich die Ukraine freuen würden meint das
dann die zusätzlichen Militärhilfen
nein das Abschluss der Community enthält
verschiedene Dinge eine wichtige Sache
die auch der Generalsekretär in der NATO
gerade eben in der Pressekonferenz
wieder und wieder betont hat ist dass
man im Fall der Ukraine bei einem
möglichen Beitritt irgendwann auf einen
Zwischenschritt verzichten wird einen
Zwischenschritt der bisher immer fast
immer vorgesehen war den sogenannten
beitrittsaktionsplan oder zu Englisch
auf Englisch den membership action plan
also nach einer Einladung wird erstmal
an Aktionsplan mit dem mittelstaat mit
dem künftigen gemeinsam erstellt und
darauf will man künftig im Fall der
Ukraine verzichten jetzt kann man sagen
ist das jetzt eine ganz große
Errungenschaft das wurde hier zumindest
als solche verteidigt und vorgebracht es
sei ein großer Schritt sagte wörtlich
der Generalsekretärs deutenberg und auch
andere haben das hier als große
Errungenschaft gefeiert
ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich so ein
großer Schritt ist wie gesagt es geht
hier um eine Zeit irgendwann und ob dann
jetzt auf eine Abkürzung gesetzt wird
oder nicht es bleibt am Ende so dass die
die Einladung nicht ausgesprochen wird
das heißt ganz konkret die Einladung
kann erst dann ausgesprochen werden wenn
sich die Alliierten einig sind und wenn
die Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind und was
das dann für Voraussetzungen sind das
wurde nicht mehr spezifiziert
ich habe hier noch mal eine Frage aus
der Community für dich die sollten wir
vielleicht mal erklären bevor wir
weitersprechen ihr fragt nämlich jemand
auf Youtube welche Pflichten hätte denn
ein Nato-Partner der angegriffen wird
was muss dieser erfüllen um direkte
Unterstützung zu erhalten das ist
vielleicht noch mal ganz wichtig das zu
verstehen
na die NATO Partner verpflichten sich
gegenseitig im Falle eines Angriffs zu
handeln als wäre das ein Angriff auf
alle auch auf sie selbst also das ist
die berühmte beistandsklausel die
beistandsgarantie in Artikel 5 des
NATO-Vertrages wie diese Hilfe aussieht
dazu sagt der NATO-Vertrag erstmal
nichts das könnte theoretisch auch sein
dass man nur eine Protestnote schickt
aber de facto wird darunter verstanden
dass auch militärisch geholfen und
eingegriffen wird also das wirklich
diese Angriff auch als ein Angriff auf
jedes Land
verstanden wird es gibt immer wieder
diese berühmte Aussage vom
US-Präsidenten oder von vielen anderen
Staats und Regierungschefs aus der NATO
man werde jeden Zentimeter des
nato-gebietes verteidigen und das wird
ja auch schon als die deutliche Ansage
verstanden dass eben die NATO eine
Militärallianz ist die sich um jeden
Mitgliedstaat von Ost bis West von Nord
bis Süd kümmert
jetzt sehen wir dich auf dem NATO-Gipfel
in Vilnius wir haben am Anfang schon
gesagt parallel ist der ukrainische
Präsident selenski quasi auf einem
konzertähnlichen Event aufgetreten und
hat eine Rede gehalten da gab es starke
Bilder dazu da haben sich ganz ganz
viele Menschen versammelt kannst du uns
denn sagen was er da erzählt hat
das war natürlich in der Tat erstmal ein
wahnsinnig starkes Bild und was für ein
Kontrast auch zu den Bildern die man
hier bekommen hat also da wurde selenski
wie ein Popstar gefeiert regelrecht der
Personenkult dazu muss man wissen dass
auch hier in Litauen die ich sage mal
Begeisterung oder Unterstützung für die
Ukraine enorm ist wenn man hier durch
die Straßen von Vilnius geht dann sieht
man nicht nur offiziell aufgehängte
Flaggen der Ukraine sondern in ganz
vielen Wohnhäusern Mietshäusern
Geschäften die blau-gelbe Flagge der
Ukraine ist da gehst hier fühlt man sich
wirklich als Frontstaat der die letzte
Bastion der NATO sozusagen ist und die
erste Version der NATO im Kampf gegen
Russland und hier fühlt man sich mit den
ukrainischen Volk extrem verbunden das
erklärt also auch diese große
Begeisterung vielleicht für jemanden wie
selenski
dann hat er dort eine Rede gehalten und
einen ganz zentralen Satz gesagt und
zwar hat er gesagt die NATO werde die
Ukraine sicherer machen das ist
unbestritten aber dann folgte der zweite
Teil dieses Satzes und er sagte die
Ukraine würde auch die NATO stärker
machen und das war noch mal sein
Argument dafür dass die Ukraine jetzt
doch bald eine Beitrittsperspektive
bekommt und in der Tat kann man darüber
auch ernsthaft reden und dieses Argument
auch nachvollziehen denn die was die
Ukraine dort gerade macht ist eben sie
verteidigt ja tatsächlich unsere
europäische Sicherheit sie ist quasi der
letzte Vorposten der NATO auch wenn sie
noch nicht zur NATO gehört
ja du unterstreist noch mal die
Wichtigkeit von dem was die Ukraine
gerade dort leistet um westliche Werte
zu verteidigen und wir haben dazu noch
eine Frage aus der Community von Sven
Odendahl der fragt wie sehr kann dieses
berechtigte zögern der NATO dafür sorgen
dass die Ukraine sich ein anderes
Bündnis jenseits der NATO sucht ist das
ein realistisches Szenario
ich wüsste jetzt nicht welches Bündnis
sich da anbieten würde im Ernst dass das
glaube ich ist kein realistisches
Szenario natürlich kann es zu einer
Entfremdung der Partner führen wenn hier
auch offen Kritik geübt wird das ist ein
Szenario was durchaus denkbar ist aber
das Streben der Ukraine in den Westen
das sehe ich auf lange Sicht erstmal
nicht gefährdet das wird wahrscheinlich
noch eher stärker werden dieser
russische Angriffskrieg hat die Ukraine
eindeutig in Richtung des Westens
getrieben wenn man sich ein paar Jahre
zurück erinnert war das ja nicht immer
eindeutig da gab es ja auch eine große
Spaltung in der ukrainischen
Gesellschaft zwischen einem östlichen
Teil der eher Richtung Russland
tendierte und an dem westlichen der
Richtung westentierte ich glaube dass
der russische Angriffskrieg bei allen
furchtbaren Dingen die angerichtet hat
da auch eine andere Folge hatte nämlich
diese Gesellschaft zusammen zu schweißen
und insgesamt Richtung Westen Richtung
NATO zu drängen
okay also ein treiben oder eine Bewegung
in Richtung Westen der Ukraine trotzdem
das hast du jetzt auch gerade noch mal
betont ist eine ein weiteres der Ukraine
zur NATO erstmal auf kurze Sicht nicht
in Sicht jetzt gibt's aber noch dieses
andere Instrument der NATO nämlich
diesen NATO Ukraine Rat und das ist ja
eine Weiterentwicklung zur NATO
ukrainekommission kannst du uns noch mal
erklären was das ist und was das ganz
konkret verändert
ja das wird tatsächlich morgen zum
ersten Mal stattfinden die
konstituierende Sitzung dieses
nato-ukraineates findet morgen statt
hier in Vilnius und zwar auf Ebene der
Staats- und Regierungschefs da treffen
sich also die 31 Staats- und
Regierungschefs der 31 bisherigen
Staaten mit dann eben dem Staats dem
Regierungschefs den Präsidenten der
Ukraine mit selenski und das neue an
dieser an diesem Rad ist das anders als
bei der Kommission sich die Alliierten
und die Ukraine da eben auf Augenhöhe
begeben begegnen alle haben eine Stimme
und zwar die gleiche Stimme vom selben
Wert in der bisherigen Kommission sah
das eher so aus dass da die NATO der
Ukraine gegenüber saß und regelmäßig
abfragt wie weit seid ihr in diesem
Bereich habt ihr da eure Hausaufgaben
gemacht und es waren die NATO die die
Tagesordnung bestimmt in dem Rad künftig
ist das anders da kann man sich eben
gleichberechtigt austauschen und die
Ukraine kann auch da wirklich selber
Themen setzen und mit der mit der NATO
über alle Fragen der Euro atlantischen
Sicherheit sprechen und das wird hier
durchaus als ja kleiner größerer Schritt
gewertet in der Sprache der Diplomaten
ist das durchaus eine ein echter
Fortschritt
in der Sprache ich sag mal das was die
Menschen da draußen im Lande bewegt ist
es sicherlich eher ein Fortschritt für
Feinschmecker nichts was jetzt für eine
ganz große Veränderung auch für das Volk
der Ukraine sorgen wird
du hast das gerade schon angesprochen es
gibt ja verschiedene Kriterien um in die
NATO aufgenommen zu werden und ich habe
ich abschließend noch eine User Frage
für dich und zwar fragt jemand auf
Youtube ohne Wirtschaft in die NATO geht
das also eine Anspielung darauf dass
dies die Ukraine durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg natürlich wahnsinnig in
Bedrängnis geraten ist bzw große Teile
der dortigen Wirtschaft einfach
aufgefallen sind
bei der NATO geht es nicht um
wirtschaftliche Fragen die NATO ist eine
verteidigungsallianz an Militär Bündnis
hier geht es darum sich gegenseitig im
Falle eines Angriffs beizustehen
insofern ist das kein Kriterium anders
eben als bei einem Beitritt zur
Europäischen Union wo das durchaus einen
Kriterium wäre dass man eine eine
wettbewerbsfähige Marktwirtschaft hat
bei den NATO ist eben ein anderes
Kriterium vielleicht noch viel
entscheidender das ist keine
gebietskonflikte gibt keine aktuelle
territorialen Konflikt oder Kriege und
das ist ja aktuell leider im Fall der
Ukraine der fallen das heißt dadurch
schaltet die Ukraine aktuell als
mögliches Land als möglicher
Beitrittskandidat für die NATO eben aus
ansonsten wird hier auch noch mal Wert
darauf gelegt dass die das Militär in
der Ukraine demokratisch kontrolliert
wird und auch dass die Korruption im
Staat bekämpft wird also auch da soll es
einen Fortschrittsbericht geben der
jährlich von den Außenministern
abgeprüft und eben auch veröffentlicht
wird also auch da gibt es noch kleinere
Kriterien die erfüllt werden müssen aber
eines ist klar die Wirtschaft die gehört
bei der NATO nicht dazu
danke Florian für diese Zusammenfassung
der Geschehnisse vom ersten Tag des
nato-gefühls danke dir
sehr gerne
so und wir schalten jetzt noch mal rüber
zum Militärexperte Gustav kressel und
sprechen mit ihm über potenzielle
Sicherheitsgarantien und weitere
militärische Unterstützung aus dem
Westen für die Ukraine hallo Herr Kresse
hallo ja wir haben jetzt gerade von
meinem Kollegen Florian gehört ein
rascher NATO-Beitritt das wird für die
Ukraine vorerst nichts jetzt sind aber
statt einem rasch unten raschen
NATO-Beitritt ja immer wieder sogenannte
Sicherheitsgarantien auf dem Tisch
können Sie uns einmal erklären was das
genau ist und welche Option ist da gibt
relativ breiten Strauß von Optionen je
nachdem wie man sich einrichten will
also die Idee ist dass die Ukraine von
der Beendigung des Krieges bis zu einem
Formeln NATO-Beitritt wenn Sie also
unter dem Schutz von Artikel 5 steht
eine Art Garantie bekommt oder
Zusicherungen von anderen
Mitgliedstaaten das im Fall eines
Angriffs diese Staaten hierbei stehen
würden Deutschland zum Beispiel hat
solche Sicherheitsgarantien für Schweden
und Finnland für den Übergang Zeitraum
von der Einladung zum NATO-Beitritt zur
Mitgliedschaft gegeben
in paar mit den USA man hatte garantiert
dass man im Falle eines bewaffneten
Angriffs auf Finnland oder Aufstehen
eben dann Finnland und Schweden zur
Seite stehen will nun ist das natürlich
bei der Ukraine nach dem Krieg ein
bisschen kompliziertere Geschichte und
es wird auch viel davon abhängen wie
dieser Krieg ausläuft oder ausgeht oder
nur sich beruhigt oder ob er durch einen
formellen Vertrag oder Abkommen wie auch
immer beendet wird
das steht noch aus es steht auch noch
aus ob zum Zeitpunkt den Anspruchnahme
von Sicherheitsgarantien das gesamte
Territorium der Ukraine unter der
Kontrolle der Regierung ist das ist auch
noch etwas was ungenau ist der tun sich
die Staaten eigentlich schwer
Sicherheitsgarantien heute wirklich
auszuformen das Problem ist das was
beiden angesprochen hat nämlich die
Israel Variante die ist
ich sag's mal so ein etwas ein
Euphemismus das erste Mal Israelis Atom
macht
die Ukraine ist es nicht Israel bekommt
mit dem Iran eine wahrscheinlich bald
Feind der atomacht ist
der Hauptverein der Ukraine ist schon
ziemlich ziemlich lang und ziemlich
vieler Thomas macht das zweite ist die
sozusagen die Beistands Garantie und
Anführungszeichen der USA an Israel ist
eben das die Vereinigten Staaten
Rüstungsgüter bereitstellen für den Fall
dass ihre angegriffen wird die Israel
ermöglichen sich zu wehren das machen
wir im Grunde während des Krieges ja
auch schon das ist ja die ganze Militär
Unterstützung die für die Ukraine rollt
das heißt das wäre im Grunde kein
keine Veränderung jetzt zum Status Quo
da wird dann eher mit Wort Metaphern
herumgeworfen um die Presse ruhig zu
stellen
um ehrlich zu sein wie gesagt das Thema
schwierig wenn man noch nicht weiß wie
der Krieg ausgeht
das Thema wird in erster Linie von den
USA abhängen weil natürlich die Frage
der nuklearen Abschreckung gegenüber
Russland eine der wichtigsten sein wird
und eben mit der zügerlichkeit mit der
beiden hier reingegangen ist
bin ich nicht korrent optimistisch dass
hier wirklich etwas
konstruktiver herausschaut und dann
haben wir in Europa das Problem dass ich
dieser kriegen nur vertagt dass ein
möglicher Waffenstillstand zwischen der
Ukraine und Russland für Moskau nichts
anderes ist das eine Pause um
nachzurüsten aufzurüsten die
Munitionsdepots wieder aufzufüllen und
dann noch mal loszulegen das ist die
Haupt Angst die die Ukraine hat
dass man jetzt mit diesem Krieg seine
Freiheit noch nicht endgültiger kämpft
sondern wieder nur einen ein zwischen
siegerinkt so ähnlich wie im Don was
kriegt wo man die Katastrophe zwar
auffällt aber nicht aufhebt und
dementsprechend gedrückt ist die
Stimmung zurzeit in Kiel
genau also das Wort
Sicherheitsgarantien wird in diesen
Tagen oft benutzt wird aber nicht
richtig ausdefiniert auch nicht von den
NATO Mitgliedsstaaten sie haben gerade
schon gesagt es kommt vor allem auf die
USA an als der größte Geldgeber jetzt
hat aber auch Deutschland ein neues
rüstungspaket angekündigt über 700
Millionen was wird das beinhalten und
was bedeutet in diesem Kontext
vielleicht auch die Absage von Beruf
Pistorius der zur Lieferung deutscher
Marschflugkörper an die Ukraine
also zuerst zum Paket das beinhaltet das
wieder flott machen von überständigen
Gerät im Bestand der Rüstungsindustrie
das ist im Grunde schon seit längerem
geplant das wird jetzt sozusagen noch
mal hervorgekehrt das Bemerkenswerte an
diesem Paket ist die weitere Verstärkung
von Patriot Flieger Abwehrraketen für
die Ukraine weil Patriot für den Schutz
von großen Städten enorm wichtig ist wir
haben ja heute wieder auch Angriffe auf
Odessa gesehen
mit mehr Patrick Batterien kann die
Ukraine mehrere Städte schützen das ist
wichtig
die Absage an masterkörpern ist das
ukrainischer Sicht bedauerlich weil
natürlich die teueres um dies hier geht
ein sehr wirkmächtiges Instrument ist
vor allen Dingen sein bunkerbrechender
Knoten Punkte in der russischen Armee
auszuschalten
ich denke aber dass die ausfrage ist
sich in erster Linie auch an der
flugzeugfrage anknöpfen wird die
Perspektive der Ukraine westliche
Kampfflugzeuge zu bekommen
sollte zum Beispiel die Ukraine Krippen
bekommen der geeignet ist für diesen
Markt diesen marschflowkörper zu
verschießen glaube ich wird sich da die
oder könnte sich da die deutsche
Position durchaus bewegen wobei
sozusagen wie man den Kanzler kennt ein
Grundproblem ist das zurzeit nur
europäische Staaten
[Musik]
längere Reichweite an die Ukraine
liefert die Briten die Franzosen
der Kanzler bewegt sich ungern aus dem
amerikanischen Schatten raus und wird
das wahrscheinlich in der Frage auch
nicht tun
ja neben diesen Äußerungen von Boris
pistorisches ging es ja heute auch um
neue verteidigungspläne der NATO gegen
den Ernstfall eines russischen Angriffs
das ist ein Dokument von über 4000
Seiten die sind geheim was weiß man
trotzdem schon über diese neuen
verteidigungspläne
ja also diese gemeinsamen
verteidigungspläne das ist sozusagen das
Kerngeschäft der NATO
integrierte streitkräfteplanung man
schaut genau wir bedroht die NATO also
wie schaut die russische Armee aus zur
Zeit eine eher hypothetische Frage weil
die russische Arme Ukraine steht und im
Grunde hat ein autogrenze kaum
gefährliches Potenzial versammelt hat
wie wird sich die wie will sich Russland
militärisch weiterentwickelt was für
Lehren könnte es aus diesem Krieg ziehen
wo will Russland aufrüsten wie wird
Russland jetzt nicht nur heute sondern
übermorgen also in zwei Jahren in 5
Jahren und 10 Jahren darstellen was für
Bedrohungen
mit was für Bedrohungen ist dann zu
rechnen und dann wie die NATO dement
gegen
stellen muss wenn sie sich eben wirklich
effektiv verteidigen will was für
militärische
Kapazitäten braucht man dann in welcher
Zeit in welcher Quantität in welcher
Qualität das heißt genau welche
Eigenschaften müssen die
der NATO assignierten militärischen
Einheiten haben für landstadtkräfte für
Luftstreitkräfte für Seestreitkräfte zu
was müssen Sie in der Lage sein wo
müssen wir sie weiterentwickeln was für
Forschung müssen wir anstrengen all das
wird hier durch debattiert und der
Unterschied zu vergangenen Konzepten im
Bereich des Baltikums wäre jetzt sein
dass man jetzt das Baltikum verteidigen
will nicht nur eine politische
abschreckungsfunktion oder eine
politische
stolperdrahtfunktion von kleinen
Streitkräften im Baltikum die ein
Auslöser des bündnisfalls darstellen
wenn sie angegriffen werden aber man
sozusagen militärisch nicht die Kräfte
hätten dass beide kommen wirklich zu
verteidigen dass beide kommen müsste
dann in einer mühsamen gegen Offensive
zurückerobert werden oder befreit werden
von NATO Streitkräften genauso wie jetzt
Carson und Riecher durch die ukrainische
Armee erst wieder befreit werden müssen
und natürlich mit dem Hinblick auf die
Art und Weise wie sich russische Truppen
im Hinterland Verhalten und gegenüber
Zivilisten Verhalten und was für
Zerstörung das im Land anrichtet war
natürlich die baltischen Staaten über
diese weiche Verteidigung nicht wirklich
glücklich und haben darauf bestanden
dass das Baltikum auch wirklich
verteidigt wird das heißt dass man hier
Truppen bereitstellt die in der Lage
wären einen russischen Angriff nicht nur
verzögern und nicht nur politisch
sozusagen die Flagge zu zeigen sondern
auch wirklich die Kapazitäten haben dem
etwas entgegenzusetzen wie das genau
ausschaut wie das über die nächsten zehn
Jahre das ist ja immer darum das
interessante wo müssen wir uns
rüstungstechnisch wo müssen wir uns
taktisch weiterentwickeln ausschaut ist
natürlich geheim die von pistoleos
angekündigte Brigade im Baltikum ist so
die erste Konsequenz eine zweite und das
dürfte das alte kommt natürlich auch
Rennen freuen eine zweite hat sich heute
mit dem oder besser gesagt gestern Abend
mit dem
hoffentlich bald
ausstehenden nato-beitritts Schweden
ergeben weil natürlich Schweden auf der
anderen Ostseeküste viel Hinterland für
die Stationierung von Luftstreitkräften
für der für das Agieren von
marinestreitkräften bietet um eben
verteidigungsoperationen im Baltikum
dann auch aus der Luft von See zu
unterstützen und bietet hier der NATO
viel tiefer und natürlich jetzt viel
mehr Möglichkeiten eine Verteidigung des
Baltikums gegen eine russische Invasion
auch wirklich realistisch darzustellen
ja und bevor wir über die aktuelle
Offensive der Ukraine sprechen schauen
wir mal was die NATO aktuell eigentlich
alles schon tut und noch Plan zu einem
Verteidigung und das hat Jonas Kapseln
zusammengefasst
die NATO schützt Ihre Ostflanke unter
anderem mit multinationalen
gefechtsverbänden sogenannten
battlegroups die gibt es eine drei
baltischen Ländern und Polen Deutschland
für den Verband in Litauen an die USA
den in Polen unter anderem als Reaktion
auf den russischen Angriffskrieg sollen
die battlegroups zahlenmäßig auf Brigade
Niveau wachsen auf rund 3000 bis 5000
Soldatinnen und Soldaten Deutschland
will dann 4000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
dauerhaft in Litauen stationieren
geplant ist der Einsatz der battlegroups
in allen Ländern der NATO Ostflanke also
auch in der Slowakei in Ungarn Rumänien
und Bulgarien dann würde es in jedem
Land jeweils eine Battle Group geben
die schnelle nato-eingreiftruppe NF soll
durch das neue streitkräftemodell
ersetzt werden und von 50.000 auf
300.000 soldatenen und Soldaten
aufgestockt werden die Truppe soll bei
akuter Bedrohung schnell einsatzfähig
sein seit dem Überfall Russlands auf die
Ukraine wurden bereits Einheiten der
schnellen Eingreiftruppe nach Osten
verlegt
ja das zu den Plänen und zu der neuen
gardenbildung
was bedeutet das denn für das deutsche
Militär ist das eine große
Herausforderung
ja das ist keine unerhebliche
Herausforderung also wenn wir uns zurück
erinnern die deutsche Bundeswehr hat ja
schon oft die sogenannte widgetf also
die very high
Chang reaction force das also die
Speerspitze dieser
Reaktionskräfte gebildet das ist eben
auch immer eine Brigade
die sitzt aber dann in Deutschland die
ist nicht verlegt auswärts und aufgrund
des Materialmangels aufgrund des Alters
von vieler Ausrüstung insbesondere des
Heeres
hat es bedeutet sozusagen diese
vitalityfregate die man alle paar Jahre
einmal stellt dass man dann im Vorfeld
dieser Stellung die ganze Bundeswehr ab
Gras nach noch funktionierenden Panzern
und noch fahrfähigen LKWs damit man
diese eine Brigade zusammenstoppelt wenn
man jetzt permanent also immer und nicht
in der eigenen Kaserne sondern im
Ausland unter den Augen der Natur
Öffentlichkeit
eine Brigade im Baltikum stellt dann
stellt das natürlich
Anforderungen an das Gerät und an die
Mannschaften das bedeutet ein viel
höheres Tempo der
sozusagen der Verlegen eines Baltikum
viel mehr Soldaten werden dort dienen
viel mehr Gerät wird auch dienen viel
mehr Gerät muss einsatzfähig sein um
diese Brigade auch zu erhalten und da
stellt sich natürlich der Wind an den
Finanzminister ob er denn auch so gnädig
wäre das zu finanzieren denn diese
Überlegungen sind es nicht neu nach 2014
nach 2016 hat sich im zugegeben der
gemeinsamen streitkräfteplanung auch
immer ein Fehler dargestellt dass
Deutschland zu einem gewissen Teil
versprach zu decken und die
Verteidigungsminister bzw Ministerinnen
damals haben jeweils in der NATO eine
gewisse truppendeckung eben versprochen
und der Finanz Minister der zufällig der
gegenwärtigen Kanzler sehr ähnlich
schaut hat dann meistens die finanzielle
Bedeckung abgelehnt die es eben
gebraucht hätte um das Realität zu
machen und ähm hier ist natürlich eine
spannende Diskussion von dem Hintergrund
Sondervermögen wird bald Ausläufen
weitere Bedeckungen das wäre etas ob man
das diesmal auch wirklich finanziert
bekommt
lassen Sie uns jetzt noch mal von den
NATO-Mitgliedsstaaten auf die Lage in
der Ukraine und an der Front blicken ich
habe dazu mal eine Karte
mitgebracht die wir hier bei heute
Laschen öfter verwendet haben vom
Sicherheitsexperten afric Brady Herr
kressel können Sie uns einmal sagen wie
der Stand der aktuellen ukrainischen
Offensive läuft es gibt ja einzelne
Erfolge und wo können wir die verorten
unter Anführungszeichen Erfolge gibt es
im Raum bachmut das ist wenn Sie hier
sozusagen
im Osten da dieser große graue Fleck das
ist dann jetzt und im Norden stellt sich
im Bach Mutter hier um die Ukraine
eigentlich mehr als Opportunität denn
aus
sozusagen heraus Planung gute Erfolge
bei der offensiv bei bei ihren
Gegenschlägen erzielt da gab es
im Zuge der Wagen am Meuterei einige
Truppen oder wagenerleute die raus
rotiert sind schlecht rein rotiert das
hat man ausnutzen können da gab da hat
man sehr starke Stellungen mittlerweile
gute Hügel Ketten unter Kontrolle von
denen man aus dann Feuer die regieren
kann und Feuer Unterstützung in
umliegende Stellungen der Russen
hineinlegen kann deshalb kann man diese
Gewinne hier ausbauen aber das muss ich
sagen das ist eigentlich ein
Nebenschauplatz also hier versucht man
russische Reserven zu binden hier
versucht man russische Kräfte zu binden
damit die nicht in den Süden gehen wenn
man so ein bisschen noch etwas südlich
gehen dann kommen wir sozusagen hier an
so ein Eckchen dass die Front macht ja
und in diesem Eckchen liegt die Stadt
oder so ein bisschen unterhalb des
Eckchen liegt die stadtwolle da und wenn
sie jetzt UPS noch ein bisschen raus das
war schon gut ja
ein bisschen rauszoomen ja wenn sie
jetzt sehen so ganz links unten im Eck
da gibt es eine zweite
Hauptverteidigungslinie sondern zweite
schwer vorbereitete Stellung die läuft
dann hier irgendwo in Tröpfchen aus ja
und etwa nördlich davon setzen die
Ukraine an um diese eine
hauptstellung die hier rot gepunktet
[Musik]
gekennzeichnet ist in etwa da ist so
eine Straße runter das ist ein Haufen
Ortschaften
entlang dieser Straße Alter jetzt
zumindest so weit raus
ich könnte jetzt mit der Maus reingehen
aber es wurscht und hier versucht man
sich runter zu schieben weil man eben da
nur eine schwere Verteidigungslinie hat
die man einmal durchstoßen muss und dann
kann man in Bewegungs Regeln angehen sie
sehen hier in einer Punkte dass die
Russen versuchen hier weitere Stellungen
zu bauen und weitere Minenfelder
anzulegen und versuchen hier sozusagen
im Hinterland den Ukraine noch mal eine
Stellung in die Wege gelegen da oben
haben sich jetzt ganz gute
stellungsverschiebungen ergeben wo ich
Ukraine wieder so ähnlich wie in bachmut
vor zwei Wochen
starke hügigkeiten genommen haben um
Feuerunterstützung in die russische
Hauptlinie hinein zu bringen und da
besteht jetzt natürlich die Chance dass
ich in der nächsten Zeit etwas tut weil
wenn wir etwas westlich scrollen also
das ist etwas westlich von dem wie wir
sehen ja noch ein bisschen westlicher
so ja Ulrike ist ist sozusagen hier hier
in wie soll man sagen ja genau in in
dieser wiege hier
an diesem Sektor waren die schweren
Gefechte die also Leopard 2,6
eingesetzt wurden etc das sieht man ja
drei Linien in der russischen Tiefe das
heißt wenn man vorne mal die Linie
durchschlägt und zum Teil haben sie die
Ukraine durchschlagen dann
steht man sozusagen im Vorfeld der
nächsten Linie und auch wenn man die
durchschlägt durch steht man im Vorfeld
der nächsten Linie das heißt hier sind
Erfolge immer nur sehr kleinräumig
möglich
hier kann man einen Durchbruch wenn man
in der Ziel viel schwieriger ausnutzen
als etwa im Osten wo man dann zwar eine
weit größere Flanke hat das heißt der
Bereich links und rechts der
angriffspitzen die man dann sichern muss
gegen russische Gegenangriffe ist größer
aber natürlich das sieht man an dem
Fehlen der roten Punkte der Raum für
Manöver ist natürlich auch größer und
der Raum
igkeit Geschwindigkeit und die
Schlagkräftigkeit von mechanisierten
Verbänden auszunutzen ist im Osten
natürlich auch höher deshalb sozusagen
stimmt der gewisse Fortschritt hier im
Südosten die Ukraine
durchaus optimistisch dass ich die gegen
Offensive nachdem sie ein sehr
schwierigen holprigen Staat hatte doch
beschleunigen wird können
sie haben es ja auch gerade schon gesagt
Erfolge muss man vielleicht ein bisschen
Anführungszeichen setzen das ist eine
sehr schleppend laufende Offensive
unterstellt sich natürlich die Frage sie
waren ja selbst vor kurzem in Kiew und
haben die Situation vor Ort mitbekommen
steht in die westliche Hilfe für die
Ukraine aktuell im Verhältnis zu dem was
die Ukraine bräuchte und da kommen wir
wieder zu unserer Frage dieses Streams
tutinato aktuell genug für die Ukraine
sehr großes fehlen haben also das die
Frage der Kampfflugzeuge
die Ukrainer sehen dass die russische
Luftwaffe sehr stark dazugelernt hat von
letzten Jahr dass sie die Einsätze
anders fliegt auf den Einsatz von
gleitbomben dass sie viel effektiver
fliegt als sie das früher getan haben
die Russen haben im Bereich Führung und
Kommando auch einiges dazugelernt setzen
technisch neue Systeme ein die in etwa
das Kopieren was die
Ukraine mit Ihrem System machen
schneller Luftschläge anzufordern um
schneller artillerieschläge anzufordern
und vor dem Hintergrund der schwindenden
Flieger Abwehrmittel der Ukraine das
eben gerade die Systeme außer und Bug
und Gecko die also für die für den also
für die unmittelbaren Schutz der Truppen
Stories Trailer unmittelbaren Schutz der
Truppen an der Front jenseits der
Reichweite von
kurz reichweitigen Systemen wie Gepard
sind das genau dieses Systeme jetzt
natürlich immer stärker fehlen weil
einfach die Raketen für dieses Systeme
schwer zu beschaffen sind und man sieht
es auch in Kiew an den verschiedenen
Denkmälern bzw
erinnerungs-piloten
den deren Tod zumindest offiziell
bekannt ist und für die ist für die es
eben auch Bilder und für die es eben
auch Gedenkstätten gibt Zeit April
dieses Jahres
sprunghaft angestiegen ist wenn wir uns
jetzt zurück erinnern an diese geliebten
Dokumente amerikanische Geheimdienste
April war für einige Waffensysteme für
einige Flieger Abwehrsysteme
sowjetischer Bauer der Kipppunkt das
heißt wir sehen ein größeres ausrücken
der ukrainischen Jagdwaffe das
bestätigen auch viele Leute in Kiel wir
sehen eine größere Abnutzung von Piloten
und wir haben genau in diesem wichtigen
Thema Kampfflugzeuge keine Perspektive
keinen klaren Zeitraum wann
westliche Kampfflugzeuge kommen wie
lange Ukraine mit dem bestehenden
Flugzeugen noch irgendwie durchhalten
muss das ist zum möhrend
das zweite ist natürlich
die die Frage der der Unterstützung mit
Boden Vehikeln also es gibt ja große
Entsetzen über den Ausfall westlicher
Kampf und Schützenpanzer nur leider ist
es so dass im Kampf und Schützenpanzer
einer vielen höheren abnutzungsrate
unterzogen sind das einfach viele
riesysteme oder fliegerarbeitsysteme das
war leider auch so zu erwarten die
Ukraine sind qualitativ sehr glücklich
mit den westlichen Systemen weil sie die
Besatzungen überleben lassen weil sie
auch im Kampf
deutlicher Vorteile gegenüber
sowjetischen Systemen haben sie sind
auch sehr glücklich für das Training
dass sie an diesen Systemen bekommen
haben und ähm ich kann da aus hier auch
insbesondere an die Bundeswehr einen
Dank ausrichten dass das Training das
durch die Bundeswehr organisiert und
durchgeführt wurde auch Hand und Fuß
haben aber es ist leider in der
Quantität in der Qualität ist es top
aber in der Quantität ist es natürlich
für die für die breite davon für die
Größe die die Armee jetzt hat mit über
60 Brigaden natürlich ein Tropfen auf
den heißen Steinen die Ukraine hatte
hier mannigfaltige Probleme das eine ist
die Ausrüstung das andere ist Ausbildung
von Truppen es gibt enorme Verluste und
Offizieren und der Unteroffizieren viele
der alten Hasen die mehrere Rotationen
dombas Krieg durchgemacht haben sind
mittlerweile gefallen
das heißt in gerade im Bereich der
Ausbildung wer bringt den jungen
Offizieren den neu rekrutierten bei wie
man zu kämpfen hat
hier laufen die Rotationen hier hier ist
man aber schon schon mit der Kapazität
sehr ausgelastet und gerade vor dem vor
dem Hintergrund eben das westlichen
Trainings ist ist da noch sehr viel
Bedarf der leider ungedeckt ist der aber
das muss man jetzt aus ukrainischer
Sicht auch sehen für viele ukrainische
Soldaten und darüber entscheiden wird ob
sie diesen Einsatz an der Front
überleben oder nicht und da ist er ist
natürlich da in Kiew bei vielen Leuten
auch enorm Ungeduld da und versteht man
vieles zögern nicht weil man weiß dass
man selber oder dass die eigenen
Ehemänner und und Söhne dieses Zögern
auch bezahlen werden
und wenn wir zum Schluss noch mal ganz
konkret auf die Frage kommen tut die
NATO genug für die Ukraine da gibt es
eine Stimme aus der Community die sagt
die Nato und EU-Mitgliedstaaten die
sollten sich erstmal um ihre eigenen
Probleme kümmern
naja so militärisch muss man sagen dass
die Ukraine sich um unsere
hauptmilitäres Problem kümmert also es
gibt zu lange die russische Krieg
gebunden ist keine große militärische
Bedrohung der NATO Ostflanke dass man
auch sehen die Ukraine leistet Armee das
wozu die NATO im gesamten geschaffen
wurde er die NATO wurde geschaffen um
eben die sowjetamine und dann später
eben wieder die russische Chemie draußen
zu halten
was die Uhren geht das ist der Ukraine
auch durchaus bewusst deshalb hätte man
auch gerne einen NATO Beitritt schneller
um mal die Sicherheit abzudecken der EU
beiträgt ist nicht nur fachlich
komplizierter es ist vielen Ukraine auch
gelegen dass der
sorgfältiger Erfolg man sieht in Polen
man sieht in Ungarn das Reformen die für
den Beitritt gemacht machen werden oft
nicht sehr nachhaltig sind man kann aus
der eigenen man hat ja auch aus der
eigenen Reform Erfahrung auch schon die
Erfahrung dass manche Reformen die mal
gut angedacht waren und ihren Papier gut
aus sahen dann in der Verwirklichung
weit unter den Erwartungen blieben
und man hat eigentlich die
Erwartungshaltung an der EU dass sie
hier sorgfältig ist die die Stimmung
unter den Ukrainern warum sie diesen
Krieg kämpfen ist klar wir wollen Teil
des bestens sein und wir wollten Teil
des Westens sein russland will es nicht
und jetzt kämpfen wir dafür dass wir das
werden und wenn wir Teil des Westen
werdens dann wollen wir das auch richtig
machen dann wollen wir keine
Zwischenposition keine halt Demokratie
und kein sozusagen klassie oder oder
semi-mitglied sein sondern dann muss das
auch ordentlich erfolgen deshalb hätte
man für den EU-Beitritt lieber mehr Zeit
und Sorgfalt und
Nachhaltigkeit dann muss aber jemand
oder da muss man irgendwie die
Sicherheit in der Zwischenzeit
organisieren und da hätte man eigentlich
gedacht dass die NATO vielleicht für die
Ukraine ein offenes Ohr hätte und da
muss man dann sozusagen den Ball zurück
zum heutigen Gipfel spielen dieses
offene Ohr ist vielleicht offen aber
auch ein bisschen schwerhörig
ja und mit diesem Bild bedanke ich mich
ganz herzlich Danke dass sie meine
Fragen und die Fragen der Community so
ausführlich beantwortet haben und
schönen Abend noch vielen herzlichen
Dank einen schönen Abend
ja es ist wahrscheinlich zu euch
durchgedrungen durchgedrungen ein super
komplexes Thema bei dem ganz viele
Fragen offen sind sind die militärischen
Unterstützung aus dem Westen genug tut
die NATO genug für die Ukraine erfüllt
andererseits die Ukraine die
Anforderungen für den NATO-Beitritt das
sind auf jeden Fall Themen die uns noch
weiter beschäftigen werden wir bleiben
weiterhin für euch dran und ich danke
euch wie immer für eure Fragen und
Anmerkungen und sagt bis bald